as russia prepares its next assault the
desperation is growing for ukrainian
civilians in the eastern part of the
country now a warning some of the
imagery you're about to see is
disturbing the death toll from a russian
attack on a train station filled with
people trying to flee has now risen to
at least 57. and a u.s official says
there's a new general in charge of
russian troops who has a brutal
reputation holly williams is in southern
ukraine this morning holly good morning
good morning we've been reporting on
alleged war crimes carried out by
russian troops during this invasion but
experts say their campaign has also been
marked by ineptitude and a lack of
professionalism now it seems moscow is
trying to fix that problem
general alexander dwornikov is the man
who's now in charge of russia's invasion
of ukraine according to a u.s official
general dvornikov previously led russian
forces in
syria where russia has been accused of
committing war crimes by the united
nations with air strikes targeting
civilian areas
general dvornikov's appointment follows
a catalogue of russian military failures
russian forces were defeated in the
battle for kiev and have withdrawn from
around ukraine's capital
the security situations now so improved
on saturday president vladimir zelinsky
walked through the city centre with
british prime minister boris johnson we
simply wish to keep supporting the
people of ukraine for as long as it
takes
ukraine claims nearly 20 000 russian
troops have been killed in this invasion
while russia's tanks and armored
vehicles have been picked off by
ukrainians sometimes using guerrilla
tactics
we've seen their burnt out carcasses
across this country
six of them died here
russia is now switching its focus to
eastern ukraine this column of vehicles
at least eight miles long was spotted
heading there three days ago
president zielenski said today that tens
of thousands of ukrainians are thought
to have been killed in the city of
mariopol which has been bombarded by
russian forces for weeks on end
gail
holly williams reporting from ukraine we
thank you